Естонія та Фінляндія межують із Росією і входять до Європейського Союзу,
який заборонив авіаперевезення з Росії після її вторгнення в Україну.
Однак як довго росіяни ще зможуть добиратися до Естонії та Фінляндії суходолом - невідомо.
Російські компанії пропонують автомобільні поїздки з Петербурга
до столиці Фінляндії Гельсінкі. Між містами приблизно 300 кілометрів.
На мій погляд, так, видача віз росіянам має бути обмежена.
Неправильно, що тоді, коли Росія веде агресивну війну в Європі,
російські туристи можуть вільно подорожувати. Але це складне питання.
Справа не лише в тому, які візи видає Фінляндія. Оскільки ми входимо до Шенгенської зони,
це також питання шенгенських віз. Ми маємо обговорити це разом
з іншими європейськими країнами на рівні ЄС та разом знайти рішення.
Серед 26 країн Шенгенської зони - 22 держави Євросоюзу, а також Ісландія,
Норвегія, Швейцарія та Ліхтенштейн. Заборонити видавати візи можна лише
за згодою всіх країн-учасниць шенгенської угоди.
Поки що рішення на європейському рівні немає, заявили у МЗС Німеччини.
У рамках рішень ради з міжнародних відносин від 25 лютого
прийнято рішення на рівні ЄС про часткове скасування угоди
про полегшення режиму - це особливо стосується скасування безвізового в'їзду
для власників дипломатичних паспортів і скасування полегшень
для членів парламенту та уряду. Що стосується видачі віз, то скасування видачі
шенгенських віз може бути введене лише на підставі консенсусу
між усіма країнами шенгенської угоди, а зараз такого рішення немає.
9 серпня зупинити видачу туристичних віз росіянам на поїздки до ЄС
закликала прем'єрка Естонії Кая Каллас.
На початку тижня президент України Володимир Зеленський закликав
країни Заходу заборонити в’їзд на свою територію всім громадянам Росії.
Він вважає, що заборона має торкнутися, зокрема, тих,
хто залишив Росію через незгоду з війною в Україні.
У Кремлі вже зазначили, що будь-які спроби ізолювати росіян чи Росію,
це - цитата - "процес, який не має перспектив" і що "ірраціональність
мислення тих, хто це пропонує, зашкалює".
Європейські ж політики і прості громадяни нагадують Росії, чому це зроблено.
Гинуть громадяни України, мирні жителі, жінки й діти в Україні,
а з іншого боку громадяни Росії відпочивають у ЄС.
Я вважаю, що це нестерпна ситуація.
Це неправильно, що росіяни можуть вільно їздити до Фінляндії.
Це позбавляє підстав для санкцій. Я думаю, що повинні бути певні обмеження.
Проти цього рішення виступають деякі бізнесмени, які ведуть бізнес з Росією,
і, відповідно, самі туристи з РФ.
Я вважаю, що це найабсурдніша ідея, яка у них є.
Що вони виграють від ізоляції нормальних російських громадян,
які не мають жодного відношення до політичних рішень лідерів Росії?
Вони створюють проблеми для нормальних російських громадян,
і вони створюють величезну проблему для місцевих жителів і бізнесу тут.
Мені буде дуже сумно. Я розчарований, тому що я дуже люблю Фінляндію
і мені подобається тут відпочивати.
Це чудова країна, природа й озера. Я буду розчарований.
Туристичні візи громадянам Росії наразі не видають країни Балтії,
Данія, Бельгія, Нідерланди, Мальта, Чехія та Словаччина.
Латвія ще навесні вирішила не видавати росіянам туристичні візи.
Але зберігалася можливість отримання довгострокових національних віз
для роботи чи з гуманітарних міркувань. На початку серпня Латвія
припинила видавати росіянам будь-які візи.
Єдиний виняток - похорон близьких родичів.
До Латвії за цей час переїхали близько тисячі росіян.
Це саме ці гуманітарні візи, які видавала країна. І з цієї тисячі людей
половина - це журналісти та члени їхніх сімей. Це теж вже у латвійському МЗС порахували.
Доволі багато журналістів сюди приїхало. Латвія створила певні умови
для їхнього роботи. І тисяча осіб - це ті, що виїхали незабаром після 24 лютого.
Треба розуміти, що в Латвії скоро вибори у сейм, і, звісно, на цьому фоні
лунають різні заяви політиків. Вони орієнтуються на настрої у суспільстві,
а у латвійському суспільстві є побоювання якщо не вторгнення,
то певної загрози з боку Росії. І, звісно, ці обмеження, які додатково
запроваджуються для росіян, у певної частини суспільства підтримку мають.
З іншого боку, Латвія все ж таки допомагає тим, хто тікає від переслідувань.
І я знаю декілька випадків, коли країна видавала статус біженця тим,
хто побоюється або кого вже переслідують, відкрили кримінальні справи в Росії.
Тому тут ситуація двояка. І як у будь-якому демократичному суспільстві
тут є різні погляди на цю ситуацію.
Міністри закордонних справ країн ЄС обговорять питання щодо віз
для росіян на неформальній зустрічі 31 серпня.